Okay so
I've been thinking a lot lately about
the natural hierarchy of the world
and how you can like see if something is
evil
and what I realized is
the natural hierarchy
is supposed to go God
man
women
children
this is the hierarchy
now what I realized is
feminism
basically is anything that disrupts this
hierarchy like this is what they're
trying to do because they're trying to
say women and men are equal
and when you say women and men are equal
that naturally goes against God
because it's disrupting the natural like
hierarchy of the world
and I was thinking about like women and
men's like true Natures right like men
are just more logical to the point
problem solvers or women it's like we're
so emotional
and I think what feminism has done as
convinced men that they're good people
for letting women be equal
and
what I realized is
what what that takes away from women
is it takes away the one thing we need
and the one thing that we really crave
which is guidance
and I realize if we don't get guidance
from our fathers the men the husbands
and we're here like we go from here to
here and we do this stupid feminism
Christian thing where like oh submit to
your husband when he follows God that's
or submit to your husband basically when
you feel like it like because then
you're like well what
what determines who's following God okay
so
we bring the women here now that's evil
because it disrupts like the natural
Order of Things
come
and then the women have no guidance
and I realize that's like the most evil
thing you can do to women
because when we have no guidance we go
towards self-destruction
and the problem is we have the society
where there are very few like masculine
leaders
even if they stay married
they've told men for a hundred years
that men and women are equal
and
you are supposed to be equal so go work
like a man
go
um
talk like a man
go get involved in men's things and they
basically just put this programming in
churches schools
um
the media
and I don't really know what their
agenda is and I don't you know I make
jokes but I don't really know who they
are but it just seems like there's like
a war
against the natural Order of Things
and I think
the most evil part is what you do in the
home when
you tell women they're equal to men is
that you take away guidance from the
children because female guidance leads
to destruction and the evilest part
about these policies is when you take
the father out of the home when you take
the
when you tell women they're equal in
relationships
um it takes away like guidance from them
now I'm not like a die-hard religious
person
um you know I'm Catholic but I probably
don't know enough or as much as I should
or do as much as I should but
my my point is I think there's something
evil
about telling women we're equal to men
and because it demasculates the men
it makes them basically slave away for
women's happiness
and it harms the women too because it
takes away the one thing we need which
is guidance
um and without it
really we self-destruct so
I was just thinking this is my morning I
don't have coffee today I have a steak
uh steak thought but let me know what
you guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel I'll talk to you next time